the media mob is still dishonest the FBI
is still politicized the doj has now
weaponized more than ever and the
Democratic party is pulling all the
strings here now with reaction house
Judiciary Committee chairman Jim Jordan
is with us you know you're on this
program an awful lot during that time
congressman and this is what your
committee is now looking into is our FBI
politicized has it been weaponized
because because we did not hold these
people accountable in 2016 they were
very emboldened it seems in in 2020
weren't they at the FBI putting cinder
blocks on the scales of that election
along with active CIA agents and former
Intel officials right
yet with Sean think about it in 2016 it
was the Clinton campaign working with
the FBI to go after president Trump in
his election his campaign in 2020 it was
51 former CIA agents and and Intel
officials working with the Biden
campaign to do the same thing so we've
seen it twice now one it was the FBI the
second one it was former Intel officials
but the same objective to go after
president Trump and keep him from being
president this report was as tough as
you could get it said the Comey FBI
failed to uphold its mission of fidelity
to the law think about that fail to
follow the laws what it found no
evidence no predicate no evidence
whatsoever to start this investigation
and then they talked about a trusted
Source who came to him and said hey this
really looks like it's the Clinton
campaign making it all up to go after
president Trump and they dismissed that
evidence and they went after him
nonetheless that's how bad this is
that's what this report shows and the
only way we we can hold them accountable
is to go at the one thing that everybody
cares about the money we have to look at
the appropriation that's the only
leverage we ultimately have in Congress
we have to look at the power of the
purse if we're ever going to get control
of these agencies who did this not just
once but multiple times how is it
possible it took so long the evidence
was right out there in in front of
everybody's eyes if they wanted it Mr
hire loyalty James Comey and how is it
they all get off scot-free why do I
believe that if any conservative was
involved in any effort like this to
alter an election in this country and
tip the scales of balance in an election
and spread outright Russian lies like
this that there would be consequences
especially members of the FBI that have
been politicized yeah no it's the double
standard and you're right if this was
conservatives who were involved in
anything like this they'd be going after
non-stop but when it's the other way
around you just never see you never see
him actually being held to account
that's why we have to look at the power
of the person we have to look at the
Appropriations process I mean this this
report it talked about this danchenko
who was the sub source for steel
danchenko was investigated 12 years ago
for Espionage and then what did the
Comey FBI do they paid him to go
validate the Steele dossier which he
couldn't do that's how bad this thing
was I mean and what they put the country
through remember this was three years
all we ever heard about was Russia and
Mueller and this investigation and
collusion and coordination none of it
was true all based on a lie and most
importantly the FBI knew it was a lie
they had no evidence and the report's
very clear in the executive summary no
evidence whatsoever to commence this
operation to commence Crossfire
hurricane they had none they did it
anyway they put our countries through it
that is the true threat to democracy we
face today is when entities and agencies
in our government behave like this FBI
did I want to ask you this are you
talking about defunding the FBI and
maybe even the CIA or a reorganization
Christopher Wray uh he could have gotten
to the bottom of this he decided not to
and then on top of that now we have
2020. FBI has a a copy of Hunter Biden's
laptop in December of 2019 they verify
it in the spring of 2020 but yet FBI
agents in the lead up to the 2020
presidential election are meeting weekly
with big Tech warning big Tech they may
be victims of a disinformation campaign
about Joe and Hunter Biden hence the
censoring of of that laptop story then
we've got the 51 dirty Intel agents as
Miranda Devine called them and they're
signing off on it and you said last week
John Brennan admitted that his signature
was purely political
yeah no the the Clinton campaign was the
where where this whole dossier started
they took it to the FBI they got it to
the FBI the Biden campaign is where the
letter from the 51 former Intel
officials started it was Tony blinken
who prompted Mike Morrell it's the same
pattern create the LIE big media runs
with the live big Tech amplifies the LIE
when we try to tell the truth they call
us names they call us Russian
sympathizers they could they attack you
and the Press is so eager to do that and
then ultimately in the end the one thing
that is always proven right is we were
right about it all along the only thing
we had wrong is in both situations it
was worse than we thought so we got to
keep talking about it we got to pass
legislation if we can to deal with it
and then we look to have to look at the
money the Appropriations and say how can
we direct These funds how can we better
position These funds what can we do to
stop this from happening in the future
all right Jim Jordan great work we'll
continue to watch what you're doing in
the Judiciary Committee hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube age and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else